en nicaragua estamos en un estado donde
se ha criminalizado a la oposición por
lo tanto cualquier persona que aspira un
cargo público y no sea un incondicional
del régimen inmediatamente se inventan
cargos lo de berenice quesada es
absolutamente ridículo al igual que las
acusaciones de los otros siete
precandidatos spears a la presidencia
ahora usted denunció la violencia por
parte de las fuerzas de seguridad en las
elecciones de 2006 en las que su tío el
sandinista haiti y leites fue candidato
en las de 2011 y 2016 que hay de
distinto en esta contienda electoral de
este año
el 2018 en nicaragua tuvimos un
levantamiento social que terminó más en
el asesinato de más de 328 personas y un
reporte de expertos internacionales en
donde la dictadura de ortega fue no sólo
acusadas se demostraron sus crímenes de
lesa humanidad desde entonces el país ha
venido una deriva autoritaria y lo que
estamos viendo es cómo se va agudizando
cada vez más y estamos frente a un
proceso ilegal y legítimo en donde el
dictador se está auto reeligiendo y la
comunidad internacional nos pasó de
comunicados pero seguimos esperando algo
sólido en medio de una organización
criminal como es el francés activista
que simplemente se ha tomado al estado
nicaragüense ahora israel llevan al
menos 32 líderes opositores detenidos en
el marco de las elecciones generales de
noviembre incluidos siete precandidatos
presidenciales la mayoría de ellos están
acusados de la nueva ley
10 55 y que consiste esta norma y cómo
está impactando las elecciones
la dictadura ha generado un tridente de
leyes represivas que son totalmente
genéricas se habla por ejemplo que es
prohibido aplaudir cualquier sanción en
contra con funcionario de la dictadura o
sea escuchar me es prohibido aplaudir en
nicaragua bajo a esta serie de leyes
espurias cualquier ciudadano que exprese
su criterio y esto no le parezca
correcto a la dictadura ya es sujeto de
ir a prisión israel como el panorama de
aquí a noviembre que va a pasar en grava
pues creo que más de lo mismo represión
y creo que es necesario es urgente que
la comunidad internacional desconozca
desde ya este proceso electoral porque
una elección no es un día de votación
una elección es todo un proceso y
nicaragua se han violado absolutamente
todas las normas que requiere un proceso
electoral esto es sin precedente lo que
está ocurriendo allá y necesitamos que
la comunidad internacional tenga también
una reacción sin precedentes no bastan
los comunicados necesitamos acciones
concretas en contra la dictadura de
daniel ortega no se están matando nos
están secuestrando nos han quitado
nuestro derecho a elegir y qué es lo que
quieren que el pueblo canadiense entre a
otra guerra civil por favor le hacemos
un llamado a la comunidad internacional
a los pueblos de otros países apoyen
israel gracias por su tiempo y por estar
con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted un feliz resto de día